guys we're here at the London Film and
Comic Con tell me who you are as if it
wasn't obvious enough already on Batman
and I'm the Joker like it personal so
why have you come as Batman and the
Joker this weekend's absolutely favorite
character of all comics one of the most
awesome things ever drawn Batman what
was been the inspiration for your outfit
why do you like him so much
a new suit I think it's just fantastic a
nice high tech it's over 110 pieces to
it you like the laces outfit is that the
is that the latest Batman you prefer as
well yes I will always say I mean I
agree with I agree with the Joker I
agree with the Joker here on mark hamill
been a top classic Joker because of his
voice but the Christian you know Chris
Nolan films with Christian Bale and
Heath Ledger I think was amazing you
know there was a new gritty there's an
increased sense to me I'm not like any
other Batman now go down in history you
know they'll always be remembered yeah
you know I just think Christian Bale was
a really really good Bruce Wayne and
Batman yeah really good what are you
looking forward to with the Dark Knight
Rises in Oakland see I don't know I am
really really apprehensive about it
because you know in the comics he gets
his back broke but he fights back I
don't know what it was exiting it's in
the book and in the trailer it says the
legend ends so I'm a bit you know I'm
that pretentious about it but I am
looking forward to seeing it okay not
this like it okay tell me how you put
this together because this is a lot of
good things going on here on though whoa
I made this ain't one I made I made a
prototype that was ages ago and it's
quite similar but also its armor and
this is latex felt like cosplay I bought
this you know such a scene it was very
realistic and then I what I did was was
due to a few things I didn't find right
with it so I modified it
and just wipe the make it as close yeah
it's good rip about what they might get
just close enough
yeah just like Tex itix in the belt up
all cow are custom-made to fit the net
that's always gonna be wearing an outfit
like this
the during event like this what kind of
things they need to know where coal
vests wear a cool vest because I mean
it's a good place you can keep really
cool in someone is compared to a lot of
events but you do still get absolutely
boiling hot you still do and just you
probably aren't quite as hot as Batman
over here are you thankfully no this
place is a lot cooler than I thought it
would be given the amount of people that
are here I expected it to be roasted and
a man in a latex suit I expected it to
be a puddle on the floor about dribbling
down well it does get hot it does I mean
I've got balaclava on under this as well
so yeah I've got exploit mix I've got a
little me Iron Mike Easley trials have
been back many things in it I can't do
it all we can't do it that's why it's a
superhero they were there though 110%
definitely you know it's worth every
every second it's so much fun
unbelievable that have fun you know
because I mean earlier I do a
two-year-old come up to me I know that's
enough she's been chasing around for
ages and you know that was that will
make the weekend that was really
worthwhile
you know guys it's been lovely to speak
to you both look great
enjoy the rest of the weekends and don't
get too hot and saw that by the clover
you